hello everyone and welcome to one of the
greatest puzzles i've ever shown on this
channel it comes uh
as a suggestion from a user on twitter
unfortunately i cannot pronounce his
handle so i'm not gonna even try but
thank you
for the suggestion i really really
appreciate it and
i mean this is a really really fine
puzzle and it's uh
uh um it's very strange that i haven't
seen it before
as i do search a lot for great things
regarding chess
on a daily basis so it's a really wild
one it's from 1967 and it's uh actually
a postmortem analysis of a blizz game
that was played between
uh henry koskinen here and yuha kasanen
and
this is the only photo uh i was able to
find of you
online that it's from a very young age
it's actually from a cut out photo from
this photo
uh that's him on the left yukagasanan in
the middle marti latin
and alan kibajo who are as the the
wikipedia article says
worshipping their idol tigran petrosian
you can't really see him in there but
that that is him you can you can um you
know
know it by by his hair and
this is a really wild one i am very
sorry that we don't have
uh the entire game but the uh the ending
is just
also very brilliant so let's just check
out what happens here
and yes for those of you who realized
what what happened here
i've actually flipped the board which is
something we don't do on this channel i
always prefer that it's uh you know
like a diagram white on the bottom black
on top
and that's how i prefer to show chess
games but as this is a puzzle
so i i don't mind i i flipped it for
your convenience
and uh yeah it's actually a mate in four
for black so
uh you can pause the video you can show
it to everyone to your of course friends
at the bar in the library and uh you
know
uh enjoy it you don't have to solve it
right away you can just uh you know keep
it
pause the video now and come back to it
like in a week you don't have to solve
it now
you can do it whenever you feel like it
in a year maybe in two years
but if you are interested in the
solution i will also
mention the solution now so for those of
you who don't want to know the solution
of the
mating 4 uh you know
don't uh listen anymore uh so this is
what happens here
so uh you might have considered a couple
of moves here obviously you've checked
the forcing moves what happens after a
captures on b4
uh so let's explore that okay a captures
on b4 with
check black of course has the capture
there's no other move the black king is
stuck here the pawn covers this square
bishop covers this where you have to
capture the pawn
and now black plays rook d7 and you
might think okay i've sold it bishop
captures queen and
rook here is checkmate after the queen
blocks that's obviously made in four
that is made in four but if if white
defends properly
uh after black offers the queen here
white doesn't have to accept the queen
sacrifice white can just play b3
and although uh black will win this game
it will not be in four moves because
white just created a square for his king
and it's not going to be enough to
to win the game for white in four moves
so a captures on b4
is not the solution here but you might
have
thought of that because the the solution
is pretty much never the one you
you think of first sometimes it is but
uh mostly not here
if it is then really i will congratulate
you immensely
another move you might have thought of
is queen to d7 it looks a bit weird
sorry queen to d2 it looks a bit weird
but it kind of works if the knight
captures if either of the knight
captured the queen for example captures
then knight
to c2 is checkmate however the problem
is after this
queen move that the rook can just
capture it and there is no checkmate
now whatever you do this is covered by
the uh by the
by the rook and if knight just goes
there it's not it's not a problem
uh you could also capture one more the
queen captures and again the queen
captures the
uh covers the f7 square so that's not
the solution to the puzzle
so those were kind of the this is kind
of a forcing move this is kind of a
black asking do you want to maybe
capture white queen
with the knight but that doesn't work
the move that works here
and again i congratulate to everyone who
found it in this video or maybe if
you're watching this two months from now
or or a year or two from now
the move is queen captures on v4 and
this is
this is in fact one of the one of the uh
most beautiful moves i've ever seen
because it it
does so much uh of course white uh only
has one
white must capture the queen these
scores are already covered by the
opponent by the bishop
so queen bishop captures queen is uh
mandatory here so bishop captures
and now you don't capture bag because if
you capture back
uh white just happily accepts this queen
captures on b4
white of course loses the queen but it's
not a problem because we already started
this puzzle with black being down two
pieces so white is completely winning
here as the material advantage
is enormous so here after bishop
captures on b4
what we've what we've done here is we've
created sort of this
gun on the trigger position you're
always ready with
pawn captures bishop but you don't want
to do it now you first want to prevent
the queen from capturing and
this is how you do it you first play uh
after this
you go rook to d2 and now by playing
rook to d2
the queen is no longer guarding the
bishop so what can you do here
well the problem is okay you might think
i'm just going to capture
the rook with the bishop but if you do
this then you've blocked
the rook's defense of this c2 square and
now knight the c2 is indeed checkmate
the knight cover uh
checks the king and all of these squares
are now covered so the bishop
in fact cannot go back the bishop must
remain there
and okay you might think okay what about
rook captures on d2
now okay you covered the c to square but
now the problem is the queen no longer
guards the bishop and now a captures and
b4 is just checkmate
so you might think okay i'm not gonna
capture with the bishop i'm not
to capture with the rook but i don't
mind i'm going to capture with the queen
so queen captures on b7
sorry on d2 but now only now
do you deliver the check with the knight
knight the c to
check and now what you've done with all
of this is that
you've managed to drag the white queen
all the way from here to here
and now to here and now the queen will
no longer be defending the bishop here
and there is no other move the king
cannot move so queen captures in c2 is a
must
and only now you play a captures on b4
and this is now checkmate as all of the
squares are covered here
and the white king has nowhere to go and
this is just uh this is just amazing
so many things happened in this game in
this position and it's only four moves
we're gonna
replay it one more time because we've
covered a lot of stuff
but basically first queen delivers check
bishop captures and
now the amazing rook to d2 and now
nothing can capture the rook is just
just i mean beautiful beautiful
beautiful stuff
i'm actually going to use this as a
maybe maybe as a thumbnail but
maybe i won't maybe it's going to be too
revealing so maybe we show something
else
but yeah rook to d2 and now nothing
works here
white can just resign but of course we
have to finish the puzzle queen captures
knight c2
check only move queen captures and now a
captures on b4 is checkmate
and uh yes i know you are you are uh
you can't wait to show this to your
friends at the bar in the library as
uh they're going to be super impressed i
know
uh but yeah a really amazing stuff thank
you for uh thank you for suggesting this
to me
uh really uh i i'm still
extremely happy when i find such a
puzzle that i haven't seen before and
apparently it's a pretty famous
puzzle so uh you know that that is weird
but i'm not complaining i mean i
i hope i discover a famous puzzle i've
never seen uh every day
uh you know for for for eternity and
it's very unlikely but you know the uh
the day started well
uh so uh that's uh that's the puzzle
hope you guys enjoyed it and that uh
you've been able to solve it either now
during the video or you know
whenever you decided to re-watch the
video a video so congratulations to
everyone
and uh for those of you who just wanted
to enjoy the show i'm sure you
you've enjoyed it after you've seen what
what happens here
uh but yeah so uh that's it guys uh i
would like to thank frederick costa
brendan gary lucas midler uh lawrence
huston and justin brockhouse for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
also it's justin brockhouse birthday so
uh happy birthday and i
i wish you had a good one you know that
you've celebrated well even though
i know that you can't really go all that
many places now but uh you know still
hope everything is well uh so yeah
that's uh the puzzle hope you guys
enjoyed it
uh and yeah tomorrow tomorrow is the
start of tata still so we're gonna be
covering that and yeah
uh once again thank you thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon guys